In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 19, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Jude.
The Holy Apostle Jude was the brother of James, Joseph and Simon, sons of Joseph's first
marriage.
He was therefore known as the brother of the Lord.
And in the number of the twelve Apostles, he followed Christ during his preaching in Galilee
and Judea.
And at the last supper he asked the Lord, Lord, how is it that thou wilt manifest
by self unto us and not unto the world?
Jesus replied, if a man love me, he will keep my word, and my Father will love him, and
we will come unto him.
After Pentecost, having received the Holy Spirit and being animated by divine zeal,
Jude preached the gospel in Mesopotamia.
He enlightened the soul with his words and healed the body with his prayer, to a test
that God's power was indeed with him.
He traveled as far as Armenia, and reaching Mount Ararat was hanged by pagans, who pierced
him with arrows, procuring him the unfading wreath of martyrdom.
In his epistle, which was very early placed among the canonical writings, the Holy Apostle
stigmatized the false doctors and heretics, who frequented gatherings of Christians to spread
their errors.
Their debauched behavior was the best proof of the falseness of their teaching, and the
apostle stating that they would be punished by God, recommended to the faithful, that
they refrain from such contact, basing themselves on the true faith, once for all delivered by
the apostles.
Thus taught, praying in the Holy Spirit and keeping the bond of charity, Christians can,
in the church, receive the grace of our Lord Jesus Christ for eternal life.
St. Jude's wife Mary gave him children, thus assuring the continuity of the Lord's line.
It is said that emperor Demetian, in 96, wanting to exterminate all David's descendants,
so that the Jews could have no more hope of the Messiah, arrested Jude's two grandsons
on the denunciation of heretics.
To a question from the emperor about their possessions, they replied that they shared a modest piece
of land that they cultivated themselves, and to back up their words showed them their
calloused and horny hands.
The sovereign then interrogated them on Christ and his kingdom.
They replied that his kingdom is not of this world but of heaven, and at the end of time Christ
will come again in glory to take possession of it and judge the living and the dead.
Reassured, Demetian, set them free and stopped his persecution.
These two saints, honored by the Christian community as martyrs and kinsmen of the Lord,
enjoyed great authority in the early years of the church, without however prejudicing
the authority of the bishops appointed by the apostles.
They lived until the reign of Trajan.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us,
and save us.